JoJosée Legault,
MiMichel David Althia Raj,
bobonsoir! Langues officielles :
OtOttawa dépose son projet
dede loi C-32.
DoDonc c'est vrai qu'on ne modie
papas souvent cette loi sur les
lalangues officielles au pays.
ToTour de table sur ce qu'il y a
llà-dedans. L'objectif, c'est de
mimieux protéger le français et
popour la première fois, on
rereconnaît que le français n'et
papas du tout dans la même
sisituation que l'anglais et on
rereconnaît que le français esta
lalangue du Québec etc. Est-ce e
çaça va changer quelque chose?
EsEst-ce que vous voyez un
chchangement politique d'attitue
imimportant? - Je vois changemet
dede culture politique quand mêe
asassez majeur. On verra
évévidemment lorsque la loi sera
adadoptée, est-ce que les moyeny
seseront? Mais le gouvernement
TrTrudeau s'éloigne carrément de
lala doctrine de Trudeau père de
cecette loi qui conféré à
l'l'anglais au français au Canaa
unun statut d'égalité. Évidemme,
c'c'était illusoire et mensonge.
LeLes deux langues n'ont jamais
étété égales et le gouvernemente
JuJustin Trudeau ne le reconnaît
dadans ce projet de loi qu'il ya
ininégalité de moyens et de
popouvoir etc. Elle reconnaît me
unune territorialité en
rereconnaissant que le français
esest la langue officielle du
QuQuébec avec toutes les nuance.
EÉcoutez, c'est vraiment un
chchangement de culture politiqe
mamajeur. Oui, parce qu'on
dedescend... vous dîtes que c'ét
irirréel et à tout le moins,
ututopique.
- - Mensonger et très politique.
- - Michel David, on dit qu'il a
unune nation québécoise qui pare
frfrançais donc c'est un
chchangement de paradigme quand
mmême.
- - Oui, c'est un changement au
plplan philosophique en tout ca.
IlIl est clair que jusqu'à
prprésent, si on dit qu'il y a
dedeux langues officielles et au
QuQuébec il en a juste une du
popoint de vue fédéral, ce que e
QuQuébec a toujours affirmé quee
gogouvernement fédéral ne
rereconnaissait pas, comme le
didisait José, le principe de la
sysymétrie entre les deux langus
auau Canada donc tout ça sur le
plplan philosophique, il y a un
prprogrès et une reconnaissancee
lala réalité. Et au plan pratiq,
c'c'est là qu'on va voir à l'use
paparce que la garantie de
seservices en français par exeme
popour les francophones hors
QuQuébec et dans la loi depuis
191969 et on sait que dans la
réréalité, ce n'est pas ça qui e
papasse. Tous les commissaires x
lalangues officielles les uns
apaprès les autres ont dénoncé e
mamanque de vigueur et de voloné
dede mettre les dispositions dea
loloi en application. Le dernier
cocommissaire a dit exactement a
mmême chose dans son dernier
rarapport alors ce n'est pas pae
ququ'une loi le 10 que ça se
trtranspose nécessairement en
rérésultats sur le terrain. Alos
ilil faudra voir mais disons que
l'l'intention est indiscutablemt
lolouable.
- - L'association des francophos
hohors Québec et je cherche la
cicitation, la fédération et jee
lala trouve pas, je vais la
trtrouver un jour, applaudit les
ananglophones au Québec disent :
atattention, danger. Comment vos
avavez vu ce dépôt du projet de
loloi?
- - Je pense que le dépôt du
prprojet de loi s'est
ststratégiquement déployé
auaujourd'hui mais si on met cea
dede côté, le projet de loi estn
chchangement complet. C'est une
loloi très ambitieuse et qui doe
plplus de pouvoir au commissair.
LeLes mesures qui sont en rappot
avavec les entreprise fédérale à
l'l'extérieur du Québec qui doie
s's'assujettir à cette nouvelle
loloi où les employés vont pouvr
trtravailler en français. C'est
trtrès ambitieux même si ça se
plplaît sur un plan de cinq ans.
CÇa sera un très gros changemen.
- - Parlons de cet aspect. Je ne
sasais pas si on peut mettre
l'l'extrait de Simon Jolin-Baree
avavant, ministre québécois. Il
didit : c'est notre loi 101 qui
dodoit s'appliquer. La ministre
vivient de nous dire : je ne vex
papas m'obstiner, je vais avoirn
obobjectif qu'il y a plus de
frfrançais dans ces lieux.
SISIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE, ministre
reresponsable de la Langue, Quéc
- - Les modalités associées
auau projet de loi québécois
seseront celles qui vont
s's'appliquer sur
lele territoire québécois,
etet c'est la responsabilité
dudu gouvernement du Québec
dede protéger le français,
alalors on doit travailler
enen collaboration avec
lele fédéral, mais...
enen s'assurant que c'est la loi
ququébécoise qui s'applique.
MEMÉLANIE JOLY, ministre fédérae
dedes Langues officielles
- - Bien, c'est pas compliqué,
onon a juridiction en matière
d'd'entreprise fédéralale.
C'C'est écrit dans
lala constitution.
DoDonc qu'est-ce qu'on veut fai?
EsEst-ce qu'on veut protéger
lele français ou on veut
s's'obstiner? Moi, je veux
jujuste protéger le français.
- - Josée.
- - Bien, écoutez, c'est à l'use
ququ'on va le voir mais sur le
plplan politique, on est en
pépériode de préélectoral au
féfédéral. On ne sait pas quand
elelle va avoir lieu évidemment,
cece faisant, tout ce discours r
ququi doit s'occuper des
cocompagnies fédérale au Québec,
lele message principal que tente
d'd'envoyer le gouvernement
TrTrudeau face au Bloc québécois
mamais aussi le gouvernement
LeLegault, c'est : on va s'en
ococcuper, les choses vont
chchanger, on va mieux protégere
frfrançais et de son côté, Simon
JoJolin-Barette doit affirmer li
auaussi son pouvoir de contrôle,
mamais dans les faits, ce qui va
susurtout être cap et dans
l'l'opinion publique, c'est qu'l
y y a un changement majeur qui
vivient de se produire à Ottawa.
- - Je vous fais entendre
l'l'opposition à Ottawa.
ALALAIN RAYES, porte-parole du C
enen matière dvlp économique, Q.
- - Projet de loi qui n'est,
ququi est déposé, mais qui n'est
ququ'une opération de relations
pupubliques, parce qu'on sait ts
quque la fin de session arrive t
quque le gouvernement libéral vt
alaller en élection
ddès l'automne.
LeLes libéraux le savent,
cocomme tous les députés
àà la Chambre des communes,
quque ce projet de loi
n'n'aura aucune chance
dede voir le jour.
ALALEXANDRE BOULERICE
chchef adjoint, NPD
- - On est le 15 juin, le 15 ju.
LeLe parlement ferme dans six
jojours. Elle sait que son projt
dede loi à aucune chance d'être
adadopté puis elle va quand même
dede l'avant. Ça, c'est
dede la petite politique
susur le dos des francophones
àà travers le pays.
C'C'est du cynisme libéral
àà son meilleur,
çaça n'a aucun sérieux.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - C'est un autre énoncé
àà caractère politique
àà l'approche d'un possible
enenjeux électorale, ou d'une
popossible échéance électorale,
paparce qu'il ne se passera rien
d'd'autre avec ce document-là qe
d'd'être déposé, faire un peu
dédébat sur sa naissance,
mamais il n'y aura pas d'é'étuds
enen chambre. Je vous rappelle
quque mercredi prochain, on fere
leles livres, c'est sans parler
quque le Sénat est pas toujours
sisingulièrement ouvert.
- - Monsieur Blanchet qui a ajoé
: : et s'ils reviennent, ce ne
sesera pas ce projet de loi. La
miministre a dit : ce serait le
mmême. On est dans la joute
popolitique. Michel David, c'est
clclair mais ils ne vont pas sur
lele fond mais sur le moment.
- - Oui, parce que sur le fond,
c'c'est difficile d'attaquer sa
cecertainement pour le bloc. Mas
c'c'est une manoeuvre électoral,
on e est à la veille d'une
élélection et le message est
lilimpide. Si vous voulez que ce
prprojet de loi devienne une lo,
réréaliser nos parce que si les
coconservateurs sont élus, on
n'n'est pas sûr que ça va être e
mmême projet de loi. Ce n'est ps
ututile. On peut appeler ça un
jajambage ou du clientélisme mas
sasa, message.
- - Ou plus poliment, on peut
apappeler ça un engagement
élélectoral.
- - Parce que sur le fond, je
didisais les communautés
ananglophones au Québec se sontn
pepeu inquiétés. Je lisais ça ms
ilil n'y a pas de quoi fouettern
chchat. On dit : il faut protégr
leles Français en situation
miminoritaire ailleurs qu'au
Québébec et au Québec, il faut
rereconnaître que le français,
c'c'est le foyer du français,
c'c'est tout.
- - Mais il y a aussi quand même
dedes choses qui vont peut-être
dodonner... rassurer les communs
ananglophones au Québec et danse
sesens que le gouvernement promt
quque dès la petite enfance
jujusqu'à l'université, on
popourrait la faire dans la lane
dede notre choix en anglais et
pupuis le gouvernement réaffirme
ququ'ils vont investir dans le
prprogramme de contestation
jujudiciaire, quelque chose qu's
vovont faire pour la communauté
ananglophone et sur la stratégie
élélectorale, les politiciens ft
dede la politique. Je dirais que
cece n'est pas du chantage
prpréélectoral. Je pense que le
paparti libéral avait un devoire
memettre ce projet de loi de
l'l'avant. Ça fait six ans qu'oa
paparlé en haver promis dans le
didiscours du trône à l'automne
dedernier alors ça serait un peu
igignorant de leur part de ne ps
l'l'avoir mis de l'avant
popotentiellement des élections.
JeJe vous rappelle qu'on n'a pas
bebesoin d'aller en élection. Il
n'n'y a rien qui les force à alr
enen élection.
- - Est-ce que ce n'est pas ce
sosoir à 18 heures 30 il y a un
orordre du jour à la Chambre des
cocommunes qui permet aux députs
ququi ne se représenteraient pas
dede faire leurs adieux? On a
ququand même ça ce soir. Pour
vovous, ce n'est pas la preuve
ététincelante qu'il y aura une
cacampagne en septembre?
- - Si bien, le gouvernement vet
vrvraiment aller en élection,
c'c'est vrai et toutes les parts
sese planifie pour avoir des
élélections à la fin du mois
d'd'août. Mais disons que s'il y
avavait une quatrième vague, one
rarappelle qu'au mois de janvie,
onon pense qu'il y aurait des
élélections au printemps il y au
la troisième vague il n'y a pas
eueu d'élection. S'il y a une
ququatrième vague, fort
prprobablement qu'il va falloir
leles repousser. Mais Mélanie Jy
nene s'est pas obstiné pour vous
didire : il n'y aura pas
d'd'élections. Elle a dit que ce
seserait un projet de loi qui lr
dédéposerait
- - et elle a promis de le
reredéposer intégralement.
- - Michel David, quand même un
pepetit mot sur la permission
ququ'on a donnée au députés de
fafaire leurs adieux si jamais l
nene devait pas y avoir une aute
sesession du Parlement à
l'l'automne.
- - Bien, c'est un secret de
popolichinelle que tout le monde
veveut aller en élection et
susurtout le gouvernement mais
cocomme le dit Althia, excuse-m,
s's'il n'y a pas de quatrième
vavague, il y aura des élections
cocomme on se le disait la semae
dedernière, le gouvernement n'a
mmême pas besoin de prétexte por
alaller en élection. Les gens
vovoient que c'est la fin normae
d'd'un gouvernement minoritaire
alalors à moins de quelque chose
d'd'extraordinaire, ce qui est
totoujours possible en politiqu,
ilil y aura élection
- - vos propos ont été entendus
d'd'ailleurs. Quand vous avez dt
çaça très clairement, genre
esessayait même pas d'élaborer n
scscénario trop compliqué pour
didire que vous êtes bloqué, vos
alallez en élection vous allez n
élélection. Après deux ans, s'is
atattendent tellement. Josée
LeLegault, à moins qu'il y ait e
rérésurgence de cas.
- - Oui, nous sommes encore en
papandémie alors on est loin
d'd'avoir terminé la vaccination
dedes deuxièmes doses etc. Donc
quque de plus en plus d'experts
papar-dellà possibilité d'une
ququatrième vague à l'automne.
DoDonc c'est sûr qu'il n'y aura
papas d'élections s'il y a une
ququatrième vague. S'il n'y en a
papas, il y aura probablement ds
élélections. Mais ce que je troe
fafascinant dans tout ce qui se
papasse aujourd'hui, c'est la
réréaction du Québec community
grgroup network qui est très en
cocolère. C'est une attaque clae
cocontre l'égalité des langues
ofofficielles et en effet, on
rereconnaît la symétrie. Donc
imimaginez si le gouvernement
TrTrudeau est réélu et qu'il pae
sasa loi telle qu'elle, il va y
avavoir des contestations devant
leles tribunaux de cette loi pae
ququ'il n'y a pas de clause
dédérogatoire et elles vont
prprobablement et même sûrement
vevenir de la communauté Anglo
ququébécoise contre le
gogouvernement Trudeau. Alors on
auaura sauté d'ironie historique
enen ironie historique jusqu'à a
fifin de ce processus.
- - Ça ressemble d'ailleurs à ce
ququi s'était passé dès l'époque
dede Meech.
LeLe gouvernement chrétien avait
dédécidé d'inscrire que le
gogouvernement fédéral était
l'l'essence du rapport Charest t
ququ'il conservait le droit et e
dedevoir de soutenir la minorité
ananglophone au Québec est
frfrancophone ailleurs et même ,
çaça n'avait pas rassuré ceux qi
vovoyaient dans la société
didistincte un sombre complot pr
enenlever des droits anglophone.
AlAlors ça ne me surprend pas,
cecette réaction.
- - Althia, êtes-vous surprise
paparce que on dit que c'est ni
plplus ni -1 attaque claire cone
leles langues officielles, les
ananglophone perdant. C'est une
nanappe symétrique a été reconn,
mamais ils sont très inquiets ls
memesures du travail. Il y a
bebeaucoup de gens qui pensent e
çaça veut dire que la petite
enentreprise familiale où il y a
plplus que 25 personnes qui
trtravail mais c'est des gens qi
trtravaillent à temps partiel,
s's'ils veulent grandir, il va
fafalloir qu'il déménage à Toroo
ouou que la plupart des gens
trtravaillent la maison. Comment
çaça va se passer? La commmmunaé
n'n'aura plus la chance de granr
etet de s'accroître et de devenr
plpleinement... devant son futur
cocomme un partenaire égal et
apapprécié dans la culture
ququébécoise. C'est vrai....
IlIl y a des gens qui se sont
ajajustés à la loi 101 et il y a
dedes gens qui vont devoir
s's'ajuster à cette loi si elle
esest adoptée et on est très lon
dede cette mesure. On n'a pas eu
dede discours en chambre et le
gogouvernement n'a pas mis... na
papas la chance de mettre ce
prprojet de loi avant la fin de
l'l'automne.
- - Mes on va en discuter
- - on va en parler en